what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay we are going to be a little bit
dangerous so we are going to cover for
the god butcher now here's the deal I
did a rundown episode on this West
before it was like Thor versus Galactus
and it was really fun because that's
what we get you know it's actually the
the later part of this story I think
it's the second half I want to say it's
God bomb where we end up getting that
but really everything from like Thor god
of thunder number one all the way up to
like number nine or number ten I think
it might even be 12 I can't remember
exactly how many issues I've taught my
head it's all one comic one cohesive
story it's all just like one great big
story but for those of you guys who are
reading Jane Foster Thor this is really
where Jason Aaron's run kicks off now
Jane Foster won't be come tour for quite
some time we actually focus almost
exclusively on odin son ah but here's
the other funny thing - I've already
recorded the origin of gore the god
butcher and I'm probably gonna release
that after this video comes out so you
guys are gonna watch this video then
watch the origin of gore and then in the
origin of gore I'm gonna act like this
video hasn't been made it's gonna be
kind of a weird scenario but uh well the
fact remains here that Thor the God
would sure is really one of the greatest
stories ever told
when it comes to the character of Thor I
mean there's that's just the way it is
it is it's so incredibly good because in
my mind it really reinvigorates and
really revitalizes Thor now once the
movie Ragnarok comes out will actually
start all the way back with Thor
Ragnarok and they get into J michael
Straczynski 's run and then Matt
fractions run which basically covers
everything leading up to this particular
story so it'll be just one great big
cohesive playlist with something like 30
videos or 40 videos by the time we get
done with it ah but it will be pretty
cool in terms of how it all comes
together that includes like fear itself
and the tie-ins and all that kind of
stuff because fear itself is really
really good so we throw the god butch or
the great thing is that we basically
join up with three different generations
of Thor now the way the Jason arrant
doesn't it pages out and it makes
perfect sense when I was going through
it it wasn't convoluted it wasn't
difficult to understand not at all
because it tells one cohesive story over
three generations one part or I guess
the part that we pick up with is an 893
ad now back when it came to Thor in the
modern day his stories are pretty
straightforward but a really writers
just kind of pick and choose what they
use from like the early days of Thor you
can really just kind of throw anything
in there I mean we've seen stories that
have been kind of thrown in with uncanny
Avengers for example or Thor fought
apocalypse when Thor was fighting
apocalypse because of the fact that
weapon that he had at the time because
it wasn't worthy to wield Mjolnir yet
wield his hammer because of because as
actually yarn Bjorn was not powerful
enough to defeat apocalypse he in turn
had the ax magically enchanted so that
it could defeat apocalypse and that was
the explanation going forward for why
the axe of Thor has a magical
enchantment on it why it's so much more
powerful than any other axe because it
needed to be in order to defeat
apocalypse these are the kind of things
that writers use in order to add things
in there because for years and years and
years the axe the one that will see him
using in this story it was really just
an accident was there like it was just a
weapon that he used so we really didn't
know the basis behind it we didn't know
why it was so capable
it just was and so that story of uncanny
Avengers offered that explanation now
the cool thing is that Thor's showing up
really in this town on the western coast
of Iceland is designed to show us that
there are a myriad of gods that exist
out there in the realm of Marvel Comics
now this is kind of a wholesale rework
by Jason Aaron um he's not like
rebooting the god mythology and Marvel
Comics not at all he's actually adding
in new information and the reason why I
say that is because when it comes to
gods in Marvel there are gods and then
there are cosmic entities and they're
two distinctly different things cosmic
entities represent an aspect of the
universe so like you know eternity
represents time infinity represents
space The Living Tribunal is basically
the judge of the multiverse the one
above all created everything and then
from there you've got like master order
and Lord chaos master order represents
absolute order in the universe
Lord chaos represents absolute chaos in
the universe and they have to exist in
balance in order for there to be chaos
and order and the in-betweener
represents that balance there are a lot
of different you know representations of
what the different entities mean but in
terms of gods you have the Greek gods of
Olympus you have the Asgardian gods of
Norse mythology you have the sky
father's which are just kind of like
these head gods of all these different
religions that exist out there
judeo-christianity more or less Yahweh
you have Vishnu you have all these
different gods that exist out there but
for years that's really all there was
it was just modern Greek mythology and
modern Roman mythology which is just
kind of a reworking of Greek mythology
you had existing religions from around
the world and the gods represented in
comic books what Jason Aaron does is he
expands that and he says other planets
and other races have their own gods and
those gods are just as real as Thor and
so
yeah it's really kind of cool because it
gives us this perspective on how it all
comes together the issue with this is if
someone's been traveling around and
someone's been killing them all now of
course again this takes place in the
past and 893 AD and so with someone
running around and killing all these
gods
well then from there is just a mission
of Thor to find out who that person is
now from here we jump to the present day
and we actually pick up on a place
called the planet indigo now the planet
indi gar will be very very similar to
the planet that belongs to - Gor the god
butcher and in fact this was explicitly
designed by Jason Aaron himself to give
us this kind of parallel between how
things could have been for Gor and how
things turned out to be for Gor and of
course we'll find more about that in our
video on on the origin of the god
butcher himself but the fact remains
here but this is really Thor just kind
of being depicted as a character who
very much hears the prayers of every
living being out there now this is also
kind of a new introduction for Jason
Aaron because Thor historically wasn't
really a God that like heard the prayers
of mortals I mean he would deal with
mortals he would fight in conflicts to
protect mortals different things like
that and it was more or less just like a
generally accepted thing that had
happened every once in a while but it
wasn't like it was a guaranteed in stone
yes Thor hears the prayers of all
mortals no matter where they are in the
universe it wasn't like it is now but
Jason Aaron is throwing this in here in
order to give us a perspective of where
Thor stands in relation to all the other
gods telling us that God's everywhere
hear the prayers sometimes they'll
answer sometimes they won't it really
just depends on what that gods
motivation are you know what they what
their motivation is if they're a god of
destruction they will not answer the
prayers of a society that's being
destroyed but if they're a god of life
then they will answer the prayers of a
society that's being destroyed because
they exist to preserve life so again
what we end up doing is we end up
picking up with one of the members of
this of this you know race on this
planet who's basically saying look we
prayed to our gods and our gods never
answered well the belief of Thor and the
knowledge of Thor is that because there
are gods out there and because the gods
of these planets would respond to their
denizens if they're not that it means
that the gods are derelict in their duty
or it means that something is wrong and
so what he does is he actually travels
to the realm of the Lords of ending are
the Lords or I guess the gods of this
particular planet only to find out that
they're all dead that they've all been
slaughtered somebody went through and
just killed every single one of them and
this is a huge thing because we're
talking about beings we don't know what
their power is but we can guarantee you
that they have your
like standard run-of-the-mill Thor
abilities super strength endurance
longevity so on and so forth and so for
someone to walk into a chamber of these
things and kill them off would be
tantamount to somebody walking into
Asgard and killing everyone like that's
somebody that just is inconceivable we
can't imagine of a scenario where a
singular being would walk into Asgard
and kill everyone shy of someone who
could just warp reality on a universal
scale so again this is a really crazy
scenario but from here we jump to
several millennia into the future to
what's left of Asgard effectively
everybody in Asgard is gone and the only
person left is old King Thor for those
of you guys who are reading or who have
been reading Jane Foster Thor but one of
the things you'll notice about old King
Thor is that his arm is missing and in
fact this is a question that I've
received time and time again and I
believed I had answered it but I may not
have in the inaugural story when Jane
Foster became Thor Jason Aaron basically
wrote a circumstance whereby
Odin's son lost his arm and he basically
used the destroyer armor as a
replacement on what this this point this
several millennia in the future this
takes place well after the events of the
modern day Thor and it seems like this
is basically the future version of the
Thor that were used to be lost his arm
but he is the sole survivor of Asgard we
don't know exactly what it is that
happened there or at least at the moment
we don't it's actually explained in a
Loki agent of Asgard but we don't know
exactly what it is that happened there
all we know is that Asgard has been
completely overrun by these blocks sir
Percy's black forces of or the god
butcher and so again it presents a very
bleak future presents a very bleak
outcome in the sense that this is
basically a multi-generational fight you
know in the past 893 ad Thor encountered
God butcher for the very first time in
the present day he's trying to track him
back down and in the future Gore appears
to have won and so it's a really cool
scenario because then what Jason Aaron
does for the rest of the story is he
connects the dots
he says if Thor meant you know Gore for
the first time in the past and then he's
tracking him down again in the present
and seems to have lost in the future
then how do we get from A to B to C and
it's so cool to see it unfold it's so
cool to see it happen because what Thor
does is he continues his journey to
basically travel around you know back in
the past in 893 AD he continues his
journey to try to track down this person
who has basically killed these gods at
which of course leads him into a direct
conflict
with gore the god butcher now the
important thing to notice here is that
again with this taking place in the past
Thor's never faced anyone like this
before Thor's never faced anyone like
Gore Gore has this necro sword that
basically allows him to kill gods now it
is the source of its power but the real
benefit of the necro sword is that it is
a weapon of the gods and so it would be
like trying to fight Superman with a
steel sword versus trying to fight
Superman with a kryptonite sword one is
gonna work and one is not the necro
sword basically allows Gore to kill gods
it's a weapon for God to kill a god and
it was previously owned by gods of
course we'll learn more about that in
the origin of gore itself but the fact
remains here that with Thor facing off
against Gork this is a hitherto
unrivaled situation Thor's never dealt
with anything like this a person who
just cannot be stopped cannot be
reasoned with all he wants to do is just
kill Thor now the cool thing about this
is that Gore has like some amazing
dialogue in this story and that's really
one of the reasons why readers love him
so much is because he's got such amazing
dialogue you know he was like look you
know I thought so many gods I thought
gods of war are you a God of War because
I fought and I've killed so many of them
I fought gods of wrath I fought all
these different gods and I've killed
them all you will be no different not
only that Thor of course charging into
battle you know for Asgard I'm Thor god
of thunder of Asgard what this does is
it turns Gore on to the idea that he can
basically begin the process of killing
even more gods by an invading Asgard so
again this is a really cool scenario
because what it does is it gives us this
conflict between two beings who have
never met before but who seem to be
virtually you know virtually equal in
power now of course jumping back to the
to the modern day this is really when
the Thor begins to realize what it is
that's going on by going through this
temple you know this this this realm
where these gods have effectively been
killed he's been harkening back on his
memories of conflicting with with with
Gork and this is when he realizes that
he previously believed he had killed
gore only to find out that gore is still
very much alive and so again this is
interesting because what it does is it
continues to sort of fill in the gaps he
continues to sort of let us know what's
going on of course finding the gods of
this planet having been killed
Thor travels to a place called
omnipotence City now omnipotent city is
new Jason Aaron invented this this is a
place that never existed before and this
is why I say he's doing this wholesale
revamp
of sorts when it comes to the God
mythology in Marvel Comics because
previously the only real meeting the
only real form of meeting among the gods
so to speak was the sky father so that
was it you know the leaders of these
various godly Pantheon and that's really
all there was
but with omnipotence City what it does
is it basically creates a central hub of
information and within omnipotent city
is basically knowledge on everything
about everything now Thor is not looking
to learn everything that there is
instead this is Jason Aaron basically
saying this library is filled with like
the stories the achievements all these
different things of every God in
existence and so what Thor begins to do
is travel around to every single realm
where these gods are supposed to exist
to every planet where these gods reside
to every moon the whole nine yards and
all he finds is dead God after dead God
they have all been butchered every last
one of them have been killed whether
it's these massive gods whether it's
these small gods whether they're tree
nymphs you know whether they're gods of
destruction gods of war it doesn't
matter
every single one of them has been
completely destroyed and completely
obliterated and so having found that all
these gods have been completely
obliterated what Thor does is he
reflects back on the final battle that
he had with Gore in the past and recalls
the cave the base of operations so to
speak death war where I'm sorry that
Gore was operating out of and so
traveling back to this location where he
intends to confront war again he
actually comes into contact for the
first time with a guy by the name of
shadrach I think it is now this is kind
of cool because shadrach's just like a
god of wine and it's really interesting
to see how like Jason Aaron is very much
invoking like this Greek mythological
godly pantheon and just kind of applying
it tomorrow and then spreading it
throughout the universe like there's
gods of wine is God's own dancing
there's gods of the harvest gods of the
hunt gods of the Sun so on and so forth
it's really cool to kind of see this
expand it out into the realm of Marvel
Comics and expand it to the universe but
the issue here is that Shadrach
basically says look the reason why all
of this is being done is because of what
you did to Gore the last time you guys
had met the last time you guys had
fought now again this is Jason Aaron
continuing to kind of expand on this
Jason continuing to essentially go
through and add the narrative to this
story that will increase the
relationship between gore and for
himself and the reason why is because
what Thor does in the modern day is he
takes Shadrach to omnipotent city with
the goal
basically saying look let's see if we
can't find this realm of Cronus you know
basically these time-traveling gods and
let's see if we can't figure out what in
the world is going on with them and see
if there's a way that we could basically
go back and defeat Gore or see what it
was that I did to led to this
circumstance in the first place and so
jumping back to the Thor in the past we
end up having this moment where during
the final battle between himself and
Gore he was effectively captured and
taken prisoner and the cool thing here
is that Gore basically you know the
reason why I say is narrative is so cool
is because he starts taunting Thor you
know now again when it comes to course
character while he is sadistic while he
is twisted his goal is to just kill gods
and so really torturing Thor is just as
much for fun as it is for you know
resulting in the death of Thor in the
first place but the other half of this
is that Gore cannot simply just kill
people by himself he needs to know where
they are he needs to be able to access
them and that's basically what he's been
doing going on a mission and just
traveling throughout the universe and
killing gods wherever he finds them just
happening to stumble across them would
take so long but if he can find a God
and he can torture that God for
information and then kill him that God
will lead him to other gods which will
lead him to other gods and in turn he'll
just be travelling around the cosmos
obliterating everything and that's what
he's been doing that's really how it all
started he basically took the necro
sword he became a god and in turn began
torturing other gods for information now
again for the character of Thor the
torture that comes here is just simply
for Gore to be able to access Asgard now
we know that if that if Gore were to
access Asgard and try to kill everybody
likely it wouldn't happen
Odin would probably kill him which begs
the question where zonad in the future
why is it that all the Asgardians are
dead again it creates kind of a really
cool narrative and it begs so many
questions and it makes things incredibly
bleak but again back in the future with
old King Thor really this is just kind
of like a continuous last stand or he's
constantly just trying to take down
these various iterations of Gore the god
butchers forces constantly trying to
tear them down time and time again at
the very least trying to defeat him and
it really seems like he's fighting a
losing battle he's a one-man army
against a veritable horde of forces
coming from Gore and it really seems
like he's just going to spend eternity
fighting and basically surviving and
that's it and the reason why I say that
is because of the fact that during this
conflict he basically fights off against
a bunch of these forces he's effectively
can
put back on his throne only for him to
continue the pattern of trying to fight
them off again and so that's really
going to be his life for the rest of
eternity is just trying to face off
against the forces of gore and never
being successful you know it's almost
like Sisyphus having to push the rock up
the mountain or whatever it was you know
that that mythological story where he's
constantly doomed
to push the rock up the mountain and
then as soon as you know when it seemed
like he's gonna get to the top it comes
tumbling back down again so it's
basically him just kind of doomed to
live out this existence forever and ever
and ever and so again what we end up
doing is we basically traveler I guess
we followed gore in the modern day in
his attempts to travel into the past
again this is really what he's been
doing as Thor has been trying to track
him down and what ultimately ends up
happening here is gore basically
accesses the chronics gods and by virtue
of spilling their own blood he's able to
use the power imbued with them to travel
back in time now the reason for why he's
doing this
is to actually travel all the way back
to the very beginnings to the formation
of all things now this is kind of an
interesting scenario because when it
comes to Marvel Comics there have been
so many different tellings of how the
universe came into existence I mean
there's the telling that was that that
comes out of the classic Thor 161 and
162 I think it is where Galactus
basically recounts his origin story to
Thor there's Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers there is al Ewing's Ultimates
to the troubleshooter story or we
basically end up seeing the new origin
of all things in existence the origins
have been told time and time again
what's usually left to the rider is what
happens after the universe comes into
existence and that's usually what
writers end up kind of building on is
looking in this and saying okay look you
know the universe came into existence
because the previous universe collapsed
in on itself it was a cosmic egg that
exploded with energy and now we have the
modern universe what happens after that
now in terms of where life comes from
this again has been explained several
times over Jonathan Hickman for example
introduced a group called the builders
and the builders basically just traveled
around the universe seeding worlds and
creating stars and so on and so forth
but if you go and you read some old
x-men stories they'll tell you that the
Celestials are the oldest living things
and the Celestials are what they are
what I basically created the universe
and then the multiverse there's a lot of
different stories that go on here but
what Jason Aaron is saying is that in
the early days 14 billion years ago
there were simply the elder gods or at
least there was
original elder God and this original
elder God gave birth to other elder gods
which in turn gave birth to more gods
which led to the creation of planets and
stars and all that kind of good stuff
and so the goal of gore is to basically
kill this elder God steal its heart
which will ran him all the power that he
pretty much needs and then from there go
forward now the reason why he had to
travel 14 billion years ago is because
elder gods don't exist anymore remember
we did our video series on you know the
history of the Marvel Universe the Elder
Gods had basically wiped each other out
to the brink of extinction there was
really nothing left I mean they're
they're all virtually extinct I mean as
far as I'm aware there are no more Elder
Gods not only that it's really kind of
like the half-life concept which is to
say you can never create anything that
is equal to yourself in some form or
fashion it will always only be a
fraction of um you know two parents for
example cannot create a child and that
child has all the traits of one parent
and none of the traits of the other
it'll have a combination of both traits
with regards to you know what goes on in
Marvel Comics it's this idea that
whenever an elder god gives birth to
another elder god that new elder god is
only half of what the original elder god
could be and so going back to the
original going back to the very first
elder god is as powerful as any elder
god is ever going to be it's basically
the creator of all things and so by
stealing its heart it basically abused
god butcher and be is with gore with all
the power that he will need or at the
very least it can offer a source of all
the power he'll ever need now the other
half of this is also just pride right
it's also just kind of testing himself
seeing what he can do how far he's come
and being able to kill an elder God a
being of such immense power means that
he is insanely capable in terms of what
he's able to do in terms of how
efficient he is the fact remains here
jumping into the past the motivation for
Gore doing everything that he's done is
because of the fact that he encountered
Thor and that's why I really wanted to
wait to this part of the story to expand
on this in order to kind of you know
give you guys a lot of the information
that was there and then tie it all
together and that's what makes this so
cool with gore the god butcher his
motivation and killing gods was singular
I mean he was just a guy who was pissed
and hated gods and wanted to kill them
because he lost his family
this is condensed origin story in ten
seconds that's all he ever did he just
traveled a cosmos and killed gods and
his motivation was to just do that he
never really had a reason to question it
he never really had a reason to believe
there was anyone out there they could
challenge him until he met Thor and then
or force Tagore to experience his very
first defeat and so what Thor
represented was the idea that there are
still gods out there who are more
powerful than Gore there are still gods
out there that Gore simply just can't
defeat because Thor for example just has
the will to win he has the fighting
experience he has the prowess he has the
strength he has the enchanted weapons at
his disposal at the end of the day
gorges can't beat him through
conventional means
and so what Gore began to do was
basically go around and kill all the
other gods that existed out there absorb
their power and then basically went back
killed an elder God for the purpose of
traveling into the future and securing
his reign and so that's ultimately
what's going on here it's essentially
trying to bypass Thor but that's the
idea is that Thor is the source of all
this he's the reason why all this is
happening he's a reason why all this is
taking place core had been killing gods
for a while but it wasn't until Thor
arrived on the scene that Gore
encountered someone that he couldn't
beat through normal means and so what is
up happening here is that within the
present day with Thor arriving to this
realm of the cronic chronics God to
discover that Gore has just jumped into
the timestream and traveled into the
future
Thor immediately follows after him and
so what is up happening here is that
modern-day Thor basically ends up
travelling thousands of years into the
future with future Thor and so both
modern Thor and old King Thor are
basically fighting side by side in their
bid to take out the forces of gore the
god butcher so what this does is it
actually ends the story on a massive
cliffhanger because the question is
asked what's going on first of all why
is it that Gore basically rules with
absolute control in the future - what
happened to earth 3 where are all the as
Guardians and for how does it end
ok so during my 1 million subscriber
live stream as short as it was it was
something like maybe 25 minutes wasn't
anything outrageous but I had talked
about how I wanted to begin shifting my
focus from Marvel Comics away from
all-new all-different marvel and focus
on some classic stories and we're gonna
test the waters here a little bit I want
to do the origin of Gore the god butcher
and the reason why is because this guy
is amazing we did the god butchers
storyline as like an episode of the
rundown which was fun but I also wanted
like I've always wanted to do like an
actual like tried and true Thor the god
butcher or I guess a Thor god of thunder
you know the god what's your storyline
explained video like I don't want to do
this for quite a while
and I've been trying to find a way to
fit it in the issue with this is that
bidi / comic story and is doing Thor god
of thunder there we go he's doing that
when the Thor movie comes out I think
and we're actually gonna kind of switch
because what I'm gonna do when the floor
movie comes out is we're gonna start
with Thor Ragnarok and then just work
our way all the way up through
Stravinsky's run you know up to this
point to God butcher assuming you guys
care about this then we'll just do this
you know God what you're running the
would you like God bomb and then we'll
do what is it last days of Midgard and
there's one more I think it is I think
last days of Midgard is the last part
but we're just gonna test the waters and
we're gonna experiment and see how you
guys respond to us doing some classic
stories with regards to Thor stuff so
gore the god butcher is a pretty cool
character he's pretty cool he's pretty
interesting and he's pretty tragic at
the same time and the reason why is
because of the fact that this was a guy
who basically just ran across the cosmos
killing every single God he found and he
was one of the most interesting stories
to have ever been done with his
character but what this does at least
what this comic does is it just kind of
goes back to the early days and it
really tells us how Gore ended up from
being you know how he went from being
just a regular guy to eventually
becoming a murderer it was just killing
gods all across the cosmos and so what
we do is we jump to about three thousand
years in the past and we actually pick
up with this pretty dark and pretty a
pretty sinister environment I mean it's
not dark in terms of you know light or
anything like that but it's a very harsh
environment it's full of all kinds of
predators but people who live on it are
nomads meaning they just travel from one
location to the next simply trying to
make their way in trying to survive in
this instance what is up happening is
the mother of gore is basically killed
by some of the natural beasts that just
kind of roam around the landscape you
know monsters or you know whatever the
the natural predators are but this in
turn instills in him a lack of faith in
gods and the reason why is because as
they make their way across this planet
and as they try to reach their their
chosen place you know their eternal land
whatever you want to call it his wife is
of course pregnant with what seems to be
you know their third or fourth child the
issue with this is that as they're
traveling his wife basically steps on
some loose rocks and she falls to her
death and so all this left to him is for
his son for at least for him to carry a
son his oldest child as well as what are
the villagers are left and try to make
their way to their chosen destination
but gore the god butcher has basically
just lost faith in gods and the reason
why is because the people pray day after
day they constantly pray
for sustenance they constantly pray for
nourishment you know the son of Gor dies
in his arms because he doesn't have
water he doesn't have any food you know
they're basically just letting this
really terrible and really crappy life
but the faith of the tribe is what gets
them through they've got their own
religious leaders around spiritual
leaders they've got guys that basically
say look we have to pray to the gods and
if we do then the gods will give us what
we need to survive now some of the Jason
Aaron is doing with this little bit of a
story is he's kind of going back and
forth with things right like he's kind
of bordering on this realm of literal
and metaphorical in the sense that we're
you know these guys basically say look
we kind of have to pray to the gods and
we have to you know beg that they will
give us the things that we need in
reality the gods will not provide them
and gore doesn't even believe they exist
all he does is he just looks around at a
really harsh environment now it's
entirely possible that this planet is
not hospitable which begs the question
how did the people you know how do they
arrive to where they are now you know
how do they evolve this far we're not
given an answer to that
the Cooby they just crash-landed here
and they've been there for you know
several generations and they're
effectively dying off because they can't
live in the environment there's any
number of reasons why this is the case
but for Gore himself he looks around and
says if the gods really cared about us
if the gods really listened to our
prayers and listened to our hopes we
wouldn't be dying of starvation
we wouldn't be dying of dehydration they
would bless us with water they would
bless us with rain they'd give us some
sign that they actually exist now of
course this in response is meant to
basically be viewed as heresy but it's
also kind of makes sense that people
would respond that way and the reason
why is because what Gore is doing is
effectively taking away their hope the
people that he's walking with the God do
they believe in are the only thing that
stands between them and just giving up
is the only thing that stands between
them and just saying yeah there's no
help coming
and then just laying down and die you
know believing that the gods will answer
their prayers if they pray long enough
is the only hope they have that their
lives will get better and that makes
sense you know nobody wants to believe
that there's no light at the end of the
tunnel people want to believe that
there's a better tomorrow on the horizon
that's just the nature of people even if
there isn't even if there's no hope of
getting out of their circumstance people
want to believe that there is now of
course Gore answering this and basically
saying that hope is nonsensical leads to
him being cast out by his own tribe and
so on the verge of dying he suddenly
meant by the arrival of two gods now
this is where Jason Aaron also plays it
a little fast and loose because how
these guys are depicted one gold one
black is clearly an allegory to good and
evil that's clearly what it's designed
to be but this also shows this sort of
you know struggle that's been going on
between the two of them for eons and
eons and eons but for those of you guys
who read the unworthy Thor and those of
you guys who read you know where Nick
Fury had basically told Thor Gore was
right this is really what it's kind of
harken announcer these gods the other
gods of this planet of this realm or
this region may very well exist but they
probably don't care about the goings-on
of people on the mundane ground you know
who it is kind of living out their
regular lives I mean how many comics
have you seen where Thor rescues a
homeless man or where Thor gives money
to a homeless man or he saves him how
many comics have there been where Thor
saves some little girl who's in an abuse
of a situation with parents or some guy
who's being beat up by a bully or
something like that you don't see those
comics those comics don't exist
the only comics that you see our
colleagues where Thor is fighting
alongside the Avengers where he's
fighting in Asgard he's going against
you know the frost giants or something
like that
it's Jason Aaron hitting at the nature
of the comics and stories that we've
seen said look maybe it is true you know
if the gods exist then why don't they
care about the small guys why don't they
care about the little guys why do they
just fight amongst themselves with all
their nonsense and that's really what's
being hit at home here with regards to
Gore because one of these gods survives
and begs for help the immediate response
of Gore is why would I help you
where were you out when my mom died
where were you at when my wife died
where were you at with all these
different members of these tribes had
died but in truth it would be like
screaming at Thor because a man's wife
was run over by a car could Thor have
really saved her possibly but there's no
guarantee that he could have it's really
just the wrath and the anger and the
emotion and the pain that Gore has felt
over the course of his life and just
experiencing loss after loss after loss
after loss that all really comes to a
head and so ultimately what is up
happening here is that some of this
power Lisa seems to be that way of this
dark God basically allows itself to be
used by Gore and it actually takes the
form of what's called the necro sword
now of course the necro sword will be a
major aspect of his character going
forward in the realm of of you know for
the god butcher of that particular story
but Gore having this power basically
gives him the ability of a god
the difference is that he doesn't quite
know how to use it yet that's the
importance is that over the course of
the next several millennia he'll
basically begin to harness his skills
and so what is a path
is that we actually transition to
another realm to a different universe
called Earth ah 1 4 4 1 2 14 4 12 I
think is what it's called and we
actually pick up you know in the future
of this universe where we basically have
like Volstagg who's normally part of the
Warriors 3 but it's clearly in shape and
trimmed-down who's being tortured and
then eventually killed by Gore and he
basically keeps kind of taunting you
know Volstagg and so on and so forth and
Volstagg even makes a claim look if you
have the power of a god and you're going
around and you're killing other gods
what do you think that makes you do you
think it makes you a good guy do you
think it makes you a bad guy it's
basically saying you v you have
essentially become what it is that you
hate the most now this particular
universe not this situation but this
particular universe is extremely
important and the reason why is because
of the fact that over the course of God
butcher and God Bomb Jason arrant will
span three different time periods he'll
span in the the really the early days of
Thor you know back when he was younger
he'll go in the present day and then
he'll go in the future the future in
this particular universe where this
matters the reason why this is important
is because this is a reality where Loki
destroyed everything on earth he wiped
out all life on Earth all the
superheroes all the humans the whole
nine yards everything is gone Loki
literally killed everybody that's where
things are different that's where it
branches off from that's what makes that
universe different everything else and
you know Thor the god butcher is you
know the past or the main Marvel
Universe or the present day in the main
Marvel Universe this is in the future of
an alternate universe and so that's one
of the cool things about that little
tidbit but anyway guys I figured it'd be
kind of a cool video to make I thought
it'd be pretty enjoyable to talk about
the origin of Gore the god butcher it's
pretty straight forward is pretty short
the reason why is because his character
gets a huge amount of development and
Thor the god butcher and the actual I'm
sorry Thor god of thunder I keep saying
Thor the god Richard um he keeps getting
he gets a lot of character development
and a Thor got a thunder Volume one and
the God butcher storyline really it's
the story that kind of made him so cool
art is amazing by Sagra make it looks
absolutely insane but in my mind is
probably the greatest Thor story ever
told
getting him to God bomb this basically
brings the end of gore the god butchers
is kind of like the the self-contained
story and that was a cool thing I mean I
imagine that you know with Jason Aaron
when he was writing the story it was all
designed to be one great big cohesive
thing I mean once the time comes when
Jason Aaron you know
announces the JSON Aaron is now leaving
for you'll literally be able to pick up
with god butcher and just read all the
way up to wherever he stopped it'll just
be one cohesive story and I have and I
will continue to say that this is the
greatest run of Thor that there's ever
been like I can I've read so many runs
of Thor I've read Matt Fraction I've
read Straczynski I've read Walt Simonson
and to me I sit down and I say this is
the best run there's ever been I mean
all the other ones are great they're fun
they're interesting I like them but in
terms of development in terms of
storytelling in terms of expansion in
terms of the art and how gorgeous it is
it's the greatest run of Thor that I
think there has ever been and so picking
up from the last video you know we're
basically talked about the idea that
Gore the god butcher had essentially
jumped to the future after grabbing a
heart and really the heart of the first
elder god this essentially fueled his
power now keep in mind as gore kills
gods and you know takes their blood
wherever the case may be he expands his
own powers and so in the future he's
become really the most powerful being in
existence among the the traditional
pantheon of gods I mean keep in mind if
like The Living Tribunal showed up and
was like okay you basically disrupted
the balance of all things but let me
chop you know we'll just phase them out
of existence eternity could destroy you
know Gore the god butcher I mean there's
a litany of ways that like Jason Aaron
could end this they wouldn't be fun but
he can in them in a whole litany of
waste but the idea here is that we
initially pick up with really I guess
with modern-day Thor and King Thor now
this is where things are gonna get a lot
more streamlined than they were because
in God butcher we were following three
eras of Thor in this story we are but
they're all in the same place so it's
only we're jumping through the past
present and the future and trying to
confine it into a story and make it make
sense instead we are basically just kind
of covering all different versions of
these floor in the same point in time so
we'll still call them like young Thor
yes I guess you know past Thor and
modern Thor and King Thor but the fact
remains here that with modern Thor and
King Thor meeting together some of the
questions we have are answered to a
degree one of the things that he
basically states is that in this era
that about 900 years before this current
moment Gore had just shown up on Asgard
and invaded Asgard proper and in doing
so he had essentially taken all the
Asgardians prisoner with the exception
of Thor himself Thor was forced to
basically stay on
guard and just thinned off against wave
after wave after wave of the black
berserkers of gore now this begs the
question what happened to Odin now when
it comes to the character of Odin we
have what's called Ragnarok Ragnarok and
we'll talk more about this once we
actually get to like the Ragnarok story
Ragnarok is basically the end times of
Asgard it is the apocalypse of Asgard
but what Thor had learned and what we as
the reader had learned was that Ragnarok
was a constantly repeating cycle that to
the Asgardians to their mind you would
eventually have Serdar who would kill
Odin Loki would launch a war against
Asgard he would invade he would conquer
Asgard Thor would be killed and then
eventually the Asgardians would be
killed and that would be yet everybody
in task guard would effectively just die
like that would be you know they die in
some grandiose battle but they would all
end up dying what we learned was that
there was this group called the ones who
sit above in shadow who have been
feeding on this cycle and so where you
know where Thor looks at the modern day
and says this is the only life that I
have in reality he's been repeating his
life over and over and over again he
just didn't know it and the ones who sit
above in shadow were feeding on this
perpetual cycle of Ragnarok now
eventually Odin figured out what was
going on and instead of Thor just
staying in Asgard Odin basically cashed
Thor out as one of the reasons why he
banished him and then confined him to
earth so that he would be raised on
earth and would eventually you know come
across this path that would lead to the
death of Odin and Thor would have the
reason to ask what's going on here
because by his own involvement with
Captain America and Iron Man different
things like that he would see the world
through the perspective of a human which
in turn would create curiosity and in
his curiosity he would want to know
what's going on with Ragnarok how does
it work and how do I stop it from
happening and so again it's really kind
of a cool scenario in terms of how that
unfolds we'll get into a far more
in-depth explanation of Ragnarok once we
get around to that story with the
release of Thor 3 but the fact remains
here that because of the fact that Thor
knows what Ragnarok is because he's
aware of Ragnarok so does King Force's
he's basically Thor in the future and so
the idea here is that in his mind Odin
has effectively just died somewhere
along a lot that's really what it is I
mean Odin has basically just kind of
moved on and Thor has what's called the
Thor force now the Thor force and the
odinforce
those are just names given to whoever it
is this wielding that particular power
the odinforce is just an insane amount
of energy that Odin has and it allows
him to
whatever it is that he wants to do at
any particular point in time it's a plot
device when Odin dies that power passes
to Thor and it becomes the Thor force
likewise it could be that both Odin and
Thor die and the power would pass to
Loki and it would become the Loki force
it's just whoever it is this wielding
that power at any particular point in
time but the fact remains that King Thor
has the has the Thor force the
difference does that remember the Thor
force is like a battery so anybody who
wields it long enough if they do not go
into the odinsleep with a Thor sleep in
this case they would just basically run
out of power and that's really what it
is he's been fighting for so long and
he's exhausted so much energy he can't
go into the to the Thor sleep he can't
rest otherwise you know there wouldn't
be anybody to defend Asgard and so the
result is that his power is effectively
almost completely defeated now with the
arrival of modern for what this does is
it rekindles hope it rekindles the
possibility that he may yet live it
rekindles a possibility that Asgard
could very well be saved at the same
time modern Thor and future Thor are
joined by past Thor and the reason why
is because of the facts the past Thor
basically has this dream where he
realizes that Gore the god butcher isn't
dead where he P recently previously
believed he had killed him one of course
black berserkers kind of throws like
this Cronus charged atom or something
like that anyway just time displaces him
and it teleports him to the future
that's really all it is of course he
rises up through the pond the difference
here is that he does not immediately
join a modern and future Thor instead
he's actually forced into being a
subject he's forced into being a slave
now the reason for this is twofold the
first half is that in the mind of Gore
he's captured so many gods already and
its power is so extreme he's not worried
about modern or future for now that will
be the really the source of his undoing
and that's his humerus the other half of
this is that because Thor is so strong
and because Thor is so capable and
because he is the one that almost killed
Gore capturing Thor is really more of
like a trophy than anything else you
know I finally captured the guy who
almost killed me you know it's basically
more kind of solidifying in his own mind
that he is indeed that god of God so to
speak that he's the one person that's
gonna bring everything crashing down and
so with this in mind what King Thor
tells modern Thor is that again
where where Gore had basically showed up
on Asgard he had captured all the
Asgardians those who fought against Gore
had basically been killed and those who
have been captured have been whisked off
to a planet on the far side of the
universe
we're gorras building a god bomb a bomb
is designed to eliminate all God's we
follow King Thor and monitor Thor over
to the location of where Gore's hanging
out at now getting a little bit more
into this whole idea of a of a god bomb
what we end up finding out is that Gore
is not entirely wrong now for those of
you guys who are reading unworthy Thor
this is why Jason Aaron's run is so
important this is why Jason Aaron's run
is so significant there's a conversation
that happens between gore and his son we
don't really know where his son came
from we don't know why he's there but
there's a conversation that happens
between the two of them and what Gore
says is that in his mind gods are
inherently evil gods are inherently bad
gods you know answer the prayers of
their followers based on a win they may
choose not to answer they may choose to
answer it's just kind of doing whatever
they want to do when they do it and how
they do it and so on so forth and so
because of that Gore wants to eliminate
them all the purpose of the god bomb is
to essentially detonate the bomb so that
when it goes off it will kill all God's
throughout the timestream gods from the
present gods from the from the past
God's in the future those who may have
been hidden away from Gore that he just
didn't know about and never caught and
killed those who were never caught and
catch you whatever the case may be they
will die all throughout the timestream
now notice the motivation of gore with
this mindset Gore is basically been
passing this information on to his son
and so when Gore's son speaks directly
with Thor who's basically working as a
prisoner Gore's son basically says look
what this is going to do is this going
to usher in a great era it's going to
usher in an era where people don't fight
over which gods real and which gods
false people won't fight over which gods
right and which God is wrong people will
not live their lives waiting for an
eternity of splendor or fearing an
eternity of hell people will live in the
moment they will value what they have
they will recognize this life is the
only life they have and they will treat
it that way they will take the most
advantage out of it that's not wrong and
that's the coolest thing about that is
because that's what Nick Fury was saying
when he whispered to Odin son and he
said Gore was right and it made him
unworthy it was the hammer realizing
that's true like its true like people
you know people like Thor they represent
the ideology that people don't value the
life they have they value the life they
hope they have and so again it's
basically never really living in the
moment that's why Jane Foster was chosen
because she's literally a person dying
of cancer every moment could be her last
and so she values what she has left her
because for her she doesn't view of the
possibility of an afterlife she was a
view the possibility of going to heaven
she views the life that she has as being
the only one she has and she looks to
make the most of it she's living in the
present not living in the future that's
why the hammer chose her and that's why
it's so cool that's why all this wraps
around and creates one great big
cohesive story because you get a little
piece here and you get a little piece
there and then you get a little piece
over there somewhere
and then it all comes together to create
this amazing cohesive story where
everything is important and that's why I
love it so much it's why it's it's such
a cool thing now for here we are
introduced to the granddaughters of King
Thor and this is really kind of cool
because these chicks they do not play
like they are they are hardcore but the
funny thing about this is that while
they are being forced to work in
subservience which is to say to
basically help build this god bomb at
the end of the day they're also planning
a way to get out and the funny thing is
that with past Thor being so young being
so brash being so reckless showing up
here having been captured is saying well
we have to fight we have to fight we
have to win we have to get our freedom
he's not thinking rationally he's not
thinking according to a plan and that's
really what Jason Aaron is hitting on
when it comes to these different
iterations of Thor and that's something
that I hope you noticed past Thor is
young
I mean he's young he's brash let's just
battle you know when it comes to
modern-day Thor modern-day Thor is a
little more reasonable he's a little
more thinking he's still quick to fight
he's still quick to battle but King Thor
is old he's wise it is basically the
steps of Thor as he becomes essentially
Odin as he eventually gets to the point
where he realizes that sometimes you
can't just fight directly sometimes you
need a plan
sometimes you have to function
accordingly sometimes you just have to
be intelligent about what you do this
was really kind of cool to see these
different iterations coming together but
of course with young Thor he's basically
told look you know get back to earth
keep your mouth shut do not draw
attention to us and the reason why is
because picking up later that night with
the the granddaughters of King Thor we
ultimately find that what they've done
is they basically constructed a bomb of
their own and the reason why is because
of the fact that in three days that god
bomb will be finished and every God
everywhere in existence will be
destroyed and when that happens all
things will essentially come crashing
down including all of them there and so
the goal is to basically destroy this
god bomb before it can go off now of
course the funny thing about this and
this is really when
the brash nature of of young Thor comes
into the equation when you simply just
grabs the bomb and races off races off
with a god bomb with the intention of
destroying it now things get a little
bit murky at this point and I would
imagine Jason arrant kind of
fast-tracked things a bit and the reason
why is because of the fact that where
the bomb is detonated we immediately
transition over to King Thor and modern
Thor whether facing off against some of
these these gods that are basically
being used like these shark gods that
are being used as kind of like guards of
the planet of gore and then there's
suddenly met with the arrival of young
Thor we don't know how he got there we
don't know you know if he was just
teleported if the god bomb went off and
he was just suddenly moved away we're
not really sure exactly why it is that
he's here we just know that he is but
alongside modern Thor in alongside King
Thor what they basically say is we have
to destroy Gore we have to kill him so
that we can make sure that all God's
everywhere survive so we effectively
have three different Thor's fighting in
the same battle and it is a sight to
behold now from here we get into the
downfall of Gore and this is one of the
greatest things about this with Jason
Aaron's storytelling he does not take a
conventional approach with ending
stories which is to say hey guys here's
a really cool event and it's done it
doesn't go that way with Jason Aaron
Jason Aaron really kind of builds up he
builds characters up and then he gives
them a gradual downfall and it's usually
an ironic downfall against the the force
of three Thor's gore cannot pull it off
and what Jason Aaron is basically saying
here is that Thor is unique among all
the gods that are in existence because
of his desire for battle because of his
desire for conflict because he's so
capable at what he does
he cannot simply just be defeated like
any sort of God when you have three of
them they are non-stop about and so Gore
literally throws every single thing he
has at them he kills other gods that are
currently a slaves to absorb their power
and increase his own and he still can't
pull it off initially and so what we end
up having is all three of these gods
racing into Gore engaging in this
massive battle which leads into them
basically kind of being I guess
catapulted into the Sun now this is kind
of cool actually this is pretty damn
amazing to be honest with you guys and
the reason why is because of the fact
that with three Thor's facing off
against Gork we would expect them to win
right like we would expect them to take
today only for Gordon you know for the
battle to end for all three Thor's to
come crashing back to earth and for Gore
to
then the one that came out triumphant
and so what Jason Aaron does is he gives
us this amazing crescendo it's almost
like this this feeling that all hope is
lost that Gore has managed to defeat
three Thor's and they all have an
incredible endurance fighting prowess
the whole nine yards and gore still wins
and so again it's a very terrifying
situation but what we end up doing is we
pick up with the wife of gore when she
basically begins to do kind of talking
to her husband now this is where the
downfall comes into play and the reason
why I say that is because of the fact
that she says look you know I look
forward to an era when the god bomb is
detonated I look forward to an era when
there are no more gods out there when
there are no more people to worship you
know and she stresses her affection by
basically referring to him and saying
you are my god in return gore kills her
and that's where the downfall comes into
play and the reason why is because of
the fact that the entire scenario is
observed by the son of gore now where
the son plays along and says look you
know yes I can't wait for this bomb to
go off yada yada yada you know we'll get
everything set up and going at the end
of the day he intends to kill his father
because his father killed his mother and
so again it's so cool because usually
whenever it comes to like dystopian
rulers or like totalitarians or
something like that the one thing they
fear is someone rising up and either
becoming a martyr or mustering all the
forces together and just outright
bringing them down it's the one thing
that Gore fears above all others he
fears someone rising up with enough
power to bring him crashing down and
it's that way with every single
narrative when there's someone with
absolute power now it doesn't mean that
they are successfully defeated but it
does mean that it is one thing that they
fear and so by going through and you
know basically charging up this god bomb
with one of the Thor's who's remained
captured by Gore as well as the other
two Thor's you know trying to climb back
into battle climbing up mountain sides
from wherever it wasn't they landed the
modern Thor is basically rescued by this
son of gore and the son of war says look
my father killed my mother I will help
you defeat my father now the reason why
this is so cool is because the son of
gore represents what Gore used to be and
the origin story of Gore Gore used to be
a guy where he was basically just trying
to live a reasonable life I mean he had
a wife he had he had children of his own
he was very mortal he was very emotional
dare I say very human in terms of how he
existed it was only after he lost
everything that he became so dark and he
became so bleak but his son is still who
Gore used
his son still cares about others his son
still feels loved steel feels emotion
steel feels affection and so because of
that in his anger in his wrath and in
his desire for revenge he takes aside
against his father and doing this it
grants a reprieve for all three Thor's
to rebound back together again and begin
the process of waging a war against Gore
trying to bring him down now this is
where things get incredibly cool because
as each one begins to take on Gork each
one of them begins to meet their defeat
and ultimately it comes down to the
modern-day version of Thor who picks up
both his hammer and the hammer of King
Thor now this is something that we've
almost never seen before I don't think
I've ever seen an instance when we've
had a Thor wield two hammers at the same
time now this is crazy because the power
of the hammers has always been something
this a little bit ambiguous and even
then when this story was written the
power behind the hammers had not been
explained by Jason Aaron now we know now
that it's just like this sentient cosmic
storm it's basically cosmic energy
inside this hammer that's been harnessed
by Odin so that Thor can use it having
two hammers composed of cosmic energy it
creates a level of power hitherto on
rivaled and so what this does with or
essentially smashing them together it
allows him to both destroy the god bomb
before it kills any of the other gods
across all time in space as well as
absorb the necro sword now what this
does is it basically transforms Thor
into the god of gods because we now have
Thor wielding the all-black necro sword
a weapon designed to do nothing more
than kill gods and destroy worlds as
well as wielding two hammers this is
probably the single greatest picture
that I've ever seen in my life when it
comes to Thor he looks so badass with
this hit with his whole his whole getup
he's just like cloud and black with two
hammers I mean it's one of the coolest
things that I've ever seen but but a
gorg has essentially lost the source of
his power that's really what it is he
has no power left there's nothing left
coming to him he is effectively as
mortal as he was in his origin story and
so because of this because of the fact
that Gore has been defeated his our son
appears to him and says look I am the
source of your defeat but what we also
end up learning is that his son is not
actually his son instead his son was a
constant so again this is really kind of
an interesting scenario because what it
does is
shows us that beep in his core once you
get past his whole desire to kill gods
gore was still very much you know human
so to speak in the sense that he wanted
offspring he wanted a life but it also
shows us that he was not just inherently
evil he may have lost his way he may
have fallen down the wrong path but at
the end of the day his motivation was to
basically create a world or a universe a
reality without gods because in his mind
the gods were the source of all
suffering that existed out there and so
it begs the question how many
civilizations have suffered how many
people have died across the universe
because the gods did not answer their
call again rolling back into the idea of
why the hammer chose to Jane Foster to
be worthy instead of allowing Odin son
to be worthy so again it's it's a
beautiful story that all kind of comes
together and you know really becomes
cohesive but in these final moments
Gore's effectively defeated by being
decapitated and that's really about it
I mean from there there's really nothing
more that goes on with this character
that's pretty much the end of him and so
what this does is it gives us kind of a
really cool epilogue in the sense that
we pick up about three days later after
this battle and since that Asgard has
turned into the sort of beacon and home
for gods across the cosmos that all gods
from all these different races are all
kind of coming back they're arriving on
Asgard it's going to serve as a major
hub of course what's left of the
Asgardians still reside there we don't
know explicitly what role that you know
Asgard will play in the future at least
not yet but at this moment we just sort
of pick up with the idea that
everybody's living out the rest of their
lives you know that the past--the or
that modern Thor are sent back to their
own times respectively a King Thor stays
in the future and and that's really yet
I mean it's really the idea that just
kind of go back to doing what they were
doing before but what this does is it
sets the stage for the arrival of
Galactus on earth and it actually sets
the stage for old King Thor versus
Goliath and the question of what it is
that happen to earth in this reality
okay so getting into Jason Aaron's Thor
god of thunder I guess you know last
days of Midgard this story's actually
split in two and it's really kind of
interesting the way this is done is
because the the part that we're gonna be
focusing on here is Thor fighting
Galactus since that's the part you guys
care about the other half of this is
basically setting the stage for like
rocks on oil to get involved with with
Malekith and his desire to launch his
war of nine realms and so on and so
forth and we'll wrap back a round of
that because that's really kind of like
ends Jason Aaron's run
back around this once we pick back up
with Thor with the release of Ragnarok
so we've got a little while we've got a
little bit of time before we jump back
into Thor again that is we might start
our x-men run and then like pause the
x-men run for thor ragnarok and then do
all the thor stories going up to this
which is Jason Aaron's run and then go
back into x-men again because there's no
chronological series of videos on the
x-men stories after the events of House
of M but we'll cross that bridge once we
get to it one thing to keep in mind and
I'm really kind of debating on whether
or not this is something that we're
gonna cover because it's not wildly
significant it's just a thing he did in
the future but essentially earth itself
is completely uninhabited because of the
fact that Loki basically obliterated all
life on the planet now this was covered
in Loki agent of ass garden and Loki
agent of Asgard was basically designed
to kind of emphasize his character the
problem with doing that is in order to
understand why blokey agent of Asgard
happens we have to understand why he's
young again why he's trying to change
his ways and in order to understand why
he's trying to change his ways we have
to understand why he was a little boy
why he was a chick all that stuff comes
out of thor ragnarok
so again Ragnarok was kind of like the
house of a more kind of like the the
reboot so to speak because of that all
we really need to know is that Loki
basically obliterated all life on Earth
and that was really all there is but
what this did is it set the stage for
the arrival of Galactus now keep in mind
this section of the story takes place
millions of years or at least maybe not
millions but thousands and thousands of
years in the future so even if humanity
hadn't been wiped out by Loki it
certainly would have died off at some
point along the line but the fact
remains here that Galactus is still
again very much alive now this really
and it'll probably drag a lot of
questions into fray this really kind of
throws them to sharp relief the nature
of seeker wars now something that I want
to point out here is how Secret Wars
fits into the chronology of events in
Marvel Comics and this is where Marvel
tends to contradict itself and mobile
comics you have a character named cable
and cable is a guy that hails from the
future the guy is a retconning machine
essentially if Marvel wants to change
something don't have cable just suddenly
travel back in time for whatever reason
and he's like I'm here to prevent this
from happening
case in point Civil War when the
original Civil War then happened cable
and Deadpool still had their team-up
comic cable jumped into the past and
said hey look mr. president if you do
this I know where this is going to lead
to and you're not going to like it so it
was basically kind of fitting it in and
so the issue with cables character is
everything that happens between right
now
at any given point in male comics and
the future is all part of cables
timeline the issue with this and the
reason why it's it's so important is
because in this particular story we're
kind of left to believe that had Secret
Wars not happened then this series of
events would have transpired some you
know five six seven thousand years in
the future and so the best way to think
about this is that whenever you pick up
a Marvel story and it says thousands of
years in the future or something like
that and it's the story that took place
before Secret Wars then basically just
act as though that story took place as
if Secret Wars never happened and for
whatever reason Secret Wars ended up
taking place and so because that is
really the only way we have to kind of
rectify these two things and sort of
bring them together but the fact remains
here remember for the character of Thor
Midgard which is basically earth had
been his home for quite some time now of
course again this really all kind of
cycles back to Ragnarok in and of itself
but at the same time it's also just the
idea of him having been a superhero on
her fought alongside the real Captain
America on the Incredible Hulk and so
many different superheroes you know
having met Jane Foster there having been
a friend to humanity in so many
different ways it's really kind of him
just sort of losing a piece of himself
and so what for routinely does is he
travels back to earth for no other
reason than to just kind of gather his
bearings and it is kind of you know pay
homage to the world
they gave him so much and is sort of
mourn over the friends that he's lost
because of the actions of Loki the
problem with this is that Thor alongside
his granddaughter's basically showing up
here is suddenly met with the arrival of
Galactus now for Thor this is as much an
affront as it is really the final battle
because remember as it stands right now
in terms of like the old gods so to
speak which is to say those who lived on
Asgard
as far back as ice card ghosts the idea
here is that Thor is really the last of
the old as Guardians and Earth is the
last refuge it's really the one thing
that he can't let go and so because of
this he actually banishes his
granddaughter's away now this makes
sense because you have to keep in mind
in the mind of Thor he's fought Galactus
so many times and while his
granddaughter's know who Galactus is
they are not prepared for the you know
the kind of power that Galactus
possesses now something else to point
out here is Jason Aaron didn't just
arbitrarily grab Galactus he wasn't just
sitting in like you know what I think we
should have some kind of a villain who
are we gonna use well let's use Galactus
and truth Galactus and Thor go way back
and just in the realm of Marvel Comics
the origin of Galactus first appeared
the Thor comics I want to say was 161
and 162 you the fact remains here that
with guard stood to Galactus and Thor
their history is extremely rich I mean
they fought side by side to defeat ego
the Living Planet they've been enemies
and they've been allies and so because
of this Thor is well aware of how
powerful Galactus is but Thor is not
without his own capabilities keep in
mind Thor is currently in possession of
the Thor force now when it comes to to
the Asgardian mythos when it comes to
Marvel Comics the concept of the
odinforce or the Thor force or whatever
you want to call it it's simply just a
source of power it's not like it is a
well it's basically just the power he
possesses now with Odin it's a little
more straightforward with Odin his
brothers had previously died alongside
Odin facing off against Serdar which is
kind of like this mortal enemy it's the
archenemy of Odin and he's actually the
guy that killed Odin going into Ragnarok
but the fact remains here that the the
Brothers of Odin basically died and
their life force Murph's with him and
gave him the odinforce and so it was
really kind of Marvel's way to just
explain here's why Odin is so powerful
and so it's almost as if it was just
kind of powers that were bestowed upon
him but again it's still kind of murky
it's not really clear how there's no
definitive explanations now this is
something that can be passed on from
person to person so it's almost like a
power that he can remove from himself
and give to somebody else it's actually
what happened during the events of
Ragnarok Thor basically spoke directly
with the odinforce so it is an actual
tangible source of energy that can exist
outside of Odin it's just with Odin all
the time and so whatever he uses it to
its completion or uses any fraction of
it he has to go into the odinsleep to
basically recharge that power but the
fact remains here that Thor you know
with Odin having died somewhere along
the line Thor is now in possession of
this force of energy and so effectively
he now has the Thor force and this is
insane because the Odin or Thor force
basically allows either one to do
whatever it is that they want to do at
any particular point in time shy of
warping reality on a universal scale it
basically just amplifies their resisting
powers in the extreme the funny thing
about this though is that as powerful as
Thor is he's not on the same level as
Galactus because we're Galactus is a
force of nature I mean you're talking
about a being with hitherto unrivaled
power with the exception of the
highest-ranking cosmic entities and even
then they dare not try to destroy
Galactus because if Galactus
we're in a hungered state let's say for
example Galactus was basically ravenous
he was absolutely feeding you know he
was dying for somebody to eat he could
probably lay waste to a litany of
different things but if Galactus is
completely full
if Galactus is totally charged with
energy you know if you were a battery
and he's at 100% I would dare say
there's almost no one who could stand in
his way
barring maybe eternity himself and even
then it would probably be a pretty
formidable challenge and so because of
that you know Galactus is not someone to
be trifled with here now the cool thing
is we get this really really beautiful
conversation between the two of them and
the idea here is that you know Thor's
question is why are you going to consume
this world this world is half dead I
mean it'll only ever give you really
half the sustenance you need it would be
like eating a half-eaten sandwich why
eat a half-eaten sandwich we didn't go
eat a whole sandwich go to another
planet that's less rich with life take
that planet there's no reason for you to
take earth but for Galactus it's more
than just consuming a planet right like
it's more than just saying well I'm
hungry right now I'm gonna go eat a
planet for Galactus it's consuming earth
because remember Galactus on earth have
a very close history I mean Galactus is
first appearance you know in Marvel
Comics came by way of the Silver Surfer
arriving on earth telling the Fantastic
Four Galactus is coming and he's going
to consume your planet and there's
nothing you can do to stop him and then
you know the Silver Surfer and the
Fantastic Four banding together to
defeat Galactus by way of using the
ultimate nullifier or at least
threatening to use the ultimate
nullifier but time and time again
Galactus has shown up on earth with the
intention to conquer it and time and
time again the earth superheroes have
basically stopped him and so furgle
actus is basically saying I finally get
the planet that I've been wanting to
consume this entire taunt it is not
necessarily a life rich planet this
planet is basically dying but for me
it's really more of just the principle
of the thing you know and that's kind of
the irony here because what it does is
it really shows how powerful earth was
in a lot of different ways and that was
something that had been touched on time
and time again I mean Thanos has
referenced that over and over again the
different alien races and Marvel Comics
at some point along the line the Shiar
Empire the Kree the scrolls near the
Badoon they've all talked about that
time and time again the earth is home to
some of the universe's most powerful
beings but the earth is also filled with
people who still live in a very
primitive capacity which is to say
politics run the show and different
things like that and so the earth was
always viewed as a very dangerous place
because if one of the super heroes like
Franklin Richards
to lose control of his powers he could
wipe out everything in existence to say
nothing of people like the molecule man
Owen Reese so again it's really kind of
a cool scenario here with regards to the
nature of the earth and how it all
functions now of course this leads into
a direct conflict between Thor himself
as well as Galactus and so again this is
really kind of cool because it's
basically like this last stand it's
really Thor doing everything he can to
try to keep this planet alive the
problem here is that it's capable as
Thor is at the end of the day he's no
Odin he's basically being toppled at
every single turn now in some ways we
could say this is Jason Aaron just
nerfing the power of the of the Thor
force just sitting down it's like okay
look you know we're gonna reduce this
power and it's not nearly on the same
level as Odin and to a degree that might
be the case I would say this is just
Jason Aaron writing this story for the
sake of writing a great story which is
exactly what he does is absolutely
amazing but in the middle of all this
Thor again going head-to-head against
Galactus is ultimately toppled and
actually just kind of kicked off the
planet and just sort of sent flying now
again this is cool because and despite
the fact that Thor is not as powerful as
Odin was it's still an incredible fight
Galactus is relishing in this right I
mean when you're Galactus and you've
been traveling around the universe for
billions of years and you show up on
somebody's planet and they fire off
their little weapons which tantamount to
throwing toothpicks at a hurricane you
know you kind of get bored of the idea
that no one can put up a real
challenging fight but then here you come
to earth you know trying to conquer this
planet that stood against you for so
long and then you find one god left with
an insane amount of power and you relish
in the challenge you're like finally you
know I have somebody to keep me
entertained so it's really kind of a
cool scenario of course once Thor is
basically kind of cast out of earth or
cast out of Midgard and sent into the
depths of space it allows Galactus to
begin going through and consuming the
planet now again the cool thing about
this is that while all this is happening
we're suddenly met with the arrival of
Thor's granddaughters now in my rundown
video this is one of the funny things it
was like hey guys are bad food shopping
but this is one of the coolest moments
in the story because Thor's
granddaughters are bad asked but not
only that one of them looks like they're
wielding Stormbreaker now Stormbreaker
for those of you guys who don't know is
basically the hammer of beta ray bill
and beta ray bill the reason why fans
love him so much and the reason why so
many people are like putinism
Cinematic Universe is because beta ray
bill is the first person to have ever
picked up Thor's hammer and it was a
huge moment when it happened Nick Fury
contacts Thor says hey look there's a
ship coming over here to earth Thor goes
to investigate
you know beta ray bill basically as part
of his race or at least as one of his uh
as his Grace's main protector you know
the protector of the korbinites comes
across Thor fights against him and then
picks up this hammer it was mind-blowing
he was just like oh my god that's never
happened before so it was a great big
huge moment and it set the stage for
Marvel to begin introducing these
moments here and there when someone
other than Thor picked his hammer up but
it was always a really really cool
moment whenever it happened but because
of everything that had taken place
Odin had basically hosted a contest
between beta ray bill in Florida to
determine who was the most worthy and
because of the fact that beta ray bill
had proved himself to be an honorable
warrior because his conflict with Thor
was not due to villainy but because of
the fact that he was a protector beta
ray bill was given his own hammer
fashioned by the dwarves at the request
of Odin and was called storm breakers so
again it's a really really cool moment
of course there's the actual yarm Dorne
there's the mace I mean there's all
different kinds of little trinkets and
so on and it really kind of shows is
that Thor really is the last of the gods
there are no other gods left in terms of
the traditional pantheon the cosmic
entities still exist out there but at
the end of the day the grandaughters
authority not necessarily able to topple
Galactus and we wouldn't expect them to
they're able to put up a pretty
significant fight a lot more than we
would expect a much greater conflict
than we would expect to see here now
again this is really kind of Jason Aaron
delving into the idea that there are
still really those individuals out there
that a part of the Asgardian Pantheon
that do the best they can in terms of
holding off various threats but it's
also the notion that the granddaughters
of Thor follow very much in his
footsteps they're just as
of straight-up battles and so of course
following this quick little skirmish
between them we end up jumping back to
Thor himself and finding out that he
effectively transitions to the furthest
part or ends up in the third the
furthest part of the universe were Gor
the god butcher had essentially been
left you know where he had been
destroyed with the necro sword is sort
of sitting out there in the middle of
nowhere and so what this does is it
basically allows Thor to grab this sword
kind of harkening back to when he had
absorbed the sword and when he had both
hammers at the same time and really just
kind of realized this is basically the
only way to take out Galactus to
basically use the sort that's designed
to kill gods now what this does is
basically gives us a little bit of
information that tells us that the
necros sward was designed for a myriad
of different purposes of the sword is
designed to kill gods but is very much
one of these weapons where its
capabilities and its level of power is
relative to whatever it's going against
or at least that seems to be the case
and so when Gore the god butcher is
using it to kill God the weapon has
enough power to kill God but when Thor
is using the necro sword it amplifies
his existing powers and allows him to
take on Galactus now at this point
Galactus isn't a pretty weakened state
and that's the other half of this
equation Galactus whatever it is that he
uses his power cosmic it's just like a
battery right it's not an infinite
source of power it's not like telepathy
it's not like the optic beams and
Cyclops his eyes it is a finite amount
of power it's it's not unlimited
and so as Galactus uses the power cosmic
it's like a battery this just kind of
slowly draining now the other half of
this is that the hungrier Galactus gets
the more desperate the more ravenous and
the more dangerous he gets the lower his
patients get and so if Galactus for
example it showed up on earth and was
absolutely starving and this conflict
had started it never would have gone on
this long he would have just been like
and you're done now and he would have
just you know obliterated Thor out of
existence killed his granddaughter's
when they showed up this thing would
have been three pages long and then
Galactus would have consumed the earth
and that would have been it but the fact
that he's getting hungry or the
faculties using more of his powers means
that now he's beginning to get more
irritated and he's beginning to get more
desperate now this is kind of the cool
thing here is because once Thor arrives
back on the scene with this necro sword
he absolutely decimates Galactus I mean
he literally just kind of plunges the
sword right through him and that's
really about it now again this is kind
of a quick ending I mean it's not
something grandiose it's not something
absolutely insane things come to an end
quick fast and in a hurry but it is this
idea that with the necro sword neo Thor
essentially has the power of a thousand
gods and going through kind of declaring
himself Thor the destroyer fighting
against Galactus and basically taking
Galactus down what this does is it
basically just kind of sends Galactus
running Sims I'm basically saying okay
look this battle is far more than it's
worth I mean you're really more of a
hassle and you're worth of this point
now this is also compounded by the fact
the Galactus physical form is absolutely
tattered I mean it's almost in complete
and total ruins just because of the fact
that the battles been so extreme so
again at this point in this conflict
we're talking about a level of power
that's so high up there the normal
people couldn't even fathom what it is
that's going on but what it does is it
also sits down and it says even if Thor
right now is not strong enough to go
against Galactus he will be he will face
off against Galactus somewhere along the
line and he will probably be successful
in doing so the other half of this is
that following this experiment Thor
actually bleeds onto the ground of Earth
and the earth begins to just repopulate
and regrow now this is not just a random
thing this is not Jason Aaron just
saying yeah man like the blood of gods
repopulate earth Thor also has the Thor
force so he has the entire energy of
Odin imbued to himself the other half of
this is that Freya is not the biological
mother of Thor the biological mother of
Thor is Gaia basically the physical
manifestation of Mother Earth and so
because of that Thor is basically taking
the life energy of Gaia and just kind of
throwing it out there on earth that's
essentially what's happening what this
tells us is that it's somewhere along
the line the earth will return to its
normal self I mean the earth will you
know just kind of regrow and and
populace will begin to come back and you
know humans will begin to grow and so on
and so forth we don't know how long that
process will take but we know that it
will but with the earth basically having
been restore the rivers and streams and
so on and so forth we actually end up
picking up with this epilogue and what
we find out is that with this all-black
necrose or basically having been you
know attached to Galactus you know that
Galactus himself actually ends up this
sort of evolving and kind of growing and
imbuing himself with the necro sword and
then somebody goes forward as the
butcher of worlds the sad thing about
this is we never find out what happens
next that's the worst part about all
that because I was like I really want to
see like Galactus the butcher of world
it's like I really want to see that
happen I really want to see when is up
taking place here but the problem is we
don't we never get to see that we never
actually get to see what takes place
instead Galactus is just kind of forced
to consume Mars and that's really about
it but at any event if you guys are new
here to come as explained make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like but yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]